j'étais comme hier autour de ce monsieur
là 4,4 alors qu'il y en ait une qui
fasse une rente ai aucun danger qu'est
ce qui s'est passé en
2002 savoir faire une erreur ça
justifiait des gens même temps il y en a
il ya une perche que j'ai pas honte à
nous c'est non assistance à personne en
danger voilà et ça c'est tous ensemble
doit tirer un problème dans la rue kent
à linky qui quittent hommes par terre
qui va pas qui va pour mourir ou qui se
blesse on doit intervenir parce que
sinon on risque est là vous avez
peut-être fournissiez le monsieur
l'année tout faux listings non montaner
oui peut-être le terme est trop généreux
mais
lorsqu'on parle d'autres pièces écoulées
on les retrouve un homme vienne la
phrase
je suis méfiant parce que maintenant
tout via et vivons aujourd'hui lyon à la
question si vous avez ça relève du bon
sens a dit la police mais
s'il vous plaît j'ai attendu mais attend
les principales d'intérêt sécher mais
c'est eux qui vont aller prier au
cimetière leur père et au monde signé
pour ça donne la parole à ceux qui sont
vivants et jean les saps qu'il a voulu
intervenir par amour à nos propos alors
comment vous pouvez appeler et désigner
des individus
après avoir commis une erreur alors on
va pas dire qu'ils ont tués pour vous
ils tuent pas mais après avoir connu une
erreur comme une erreur pendant
l'interpellation donc avoir utilisé une
technique d'interpellations qui a tué un
homme se pose comment vous pouvez
appeler ça au moment où ils ont tué où
il était sans vie ils ont laissé
commander chez sur le bitume on perd au
pied de la tour et 3 donc je n'ai pas
milité comme vous pas loin de moi soul
est loin de moi lundi excusez moi
l'émission que je pose donc comment vous
pouvez appeler des arts des signes et
d'individus si finalement après avoir
commis une erreur et on va pas employer
le mot le terme tuer mais laissées sans
vie loin de main un jury toi et l'indre
non j'ai pas trop quand fut doyen par
lettre à terre et après la seule chose
qu'ils ont pensé au lieu de prendre
leurs responsabilités et de venir au
secours de cet homme qui est mon père
qui était au sol sur le bitume sans vie
ils sont mis d'accord sur une version
ils ont pris le temps de contacter leurs
collègues bas pour appeler les secours
en matinée mais écoutez madame déjà
écouté
mais je peux je peux répondre à ça pour
vous écoutez madame loin de moi l'idée
de justifier quelque crime que ce soit
surtout s'ils proviennent de la police
c'est pas mal du tout ma démarche ma
démarche c'est que un tout la police ne
tue pas 2 2 nous sommes donc de nous
sommes dans un état de droit vous on
n'arrête pas de me mobiliser de
convoquer à tort et à travers l'état de
droit quand il s'agit d'autres problèmes
dans d'autres quartiers là il ya un état
de droit si des erreurs ont été commises
il appartient à la justice aux
inspections compétentes de du ministère
de l'intérieur de déterminer les
responsabilités quand en plus ils vont
aussi justifé un bel essai plis faut
aussi tenir compte quand la brise et
riot la police fusion donne si vous
arrêtez vous enfuir des doigts d'honneur
et des bras d'honneur en blanc et deux
bras décor
mérite de mourir non j'ai pas dit ça
j'ai dit que dans un pays démocratique
la police circule intime l'ordre de nous
arrêter mais vous invitez gens mais si
cela vous est si vous essayez de passer
ont frappé je suis vous mettez le
remerciera grenache qui effectivement
pas le sien